PROFESSOR: Now,
let's talk briefly
about different types of
ventilation and different ways
that they can mix or not
mix the air in a room.
So the first type, which
is what we've mainly
been talking about, is
so-called mixing ventilation.
So this is when the colder
air is forced from above--
or in other cases,
the warmer air
is forced from
below-- in such a way
that there's an unstable
thermal gradient,
so that the buoyancy forces end
up contributing towards mixing.
And then you can see that
if a person's in the room,
the natural thermal plume rising
around that person of warmer
air, as well as the
respiratory plume
sketched here in yellow
from all the breathing--
both of them are kind of rising
and then well mixed in the room
before they're finally
removed by the outlet
of the ventilation.
And so that is the situation
we've been mainly talking
about of the well-mixed room.
But it's worth considering
that in some other cases,
the ventilation specifically
is set up to reduce mixing.
So especially in rooms
that have high ceilings,
it can be advantageous to set
up a stratified ambient, where
the thermal plume from
the body is rising
as well as the respiratory
plumes and are collecting
in the upper area of the room
where they're being gently
sucked out as the colder air is
being pumped in now from below.
So that's actually a
stable thermal gradient.
And so at least
the buoyancy forces
are not leading to any
large scale convection,
although there certainly are
still boundary layer flows
and plumes from the people
and from their motion,
as I have described earlier.
One advantage here is
that if a mask is worn,
then the respiratory droplets
coming from breathing, which
are sketched here in
yellow, are kind of
brought closer to the thermal
plume and forced to rise more.
So it basically causes
the little droplet--
let's say, the
infectious aerosols
from the breath
to be more likely
swept to the upper
reaches, where
they might sit at the
higher levels of the room
and then be sucked out.
So that can actually
be a situation
where a less well-mixed
room can be better.
On the other hand, the
advantage of a well-mixed room
is that the pathogen
in the droplets
is diluted throughout
a larger space.
And that can be
more advantageous.
But in any case, this
situation with high ceilings
and especially with natural
ventilation, where you set up
a stratified ambient,
is a strategy that's
been used for a long time.
In fact, Florence
Nightingale, in the 1800s,
recommended that
hospitals should
have high ceilings
and good ventilation
for protection against
airborne pathogens.